sie waren lange nicht in der lage über
das zu sprechen was ihnen körperlich und
seelisch angetan wurde nun erheben
kohlbacher und kelvin uhr ihre stimmen
die beiden uiguren gehören zu den
wenigen die aus chinesischen gulags
lebend entkommen konnten im bayerischen
landtag berichten sie über gewalt
erniedrigung und folter wir waren
dreißig personen in einem raum alle
waren angekettet in der nacht wurden wir
gezwungen bei unter minus 30 grad
draußen zu laufen man wollte uns quälen
und unsere widerstandskraft brechen
menschen werden gefesselt und bekommen
elektroschocks andere werden mit strom
stücken misshandelt viele verschwinden
frauen werden in gruppen vergewaltigte
und zur sterilisation gezwungen auch ich
wurde auf anordnung der chinesischen
behörden im mai 2009 10
zwangssterilisiert
die un schätzt dass rund eine million
angehörige des muslimischen turkvolkes
der uiguren in der region shin young im
nordwesten chinas in arbeitslagern
willkürlich inhaftiert sind um sie auf
die linie der kommunistischen partei zu
zwingen die staatsmacht in peking
wiegelt ab all das sei nur
ausbildungszentren
dass dem nicht so ist kann google habe
zeugen die ingenieurin hatte mit ihrem
mann und ihren kindern bereits seit zehn
jahren im exil in frankreich gelebt als
sie im november 2016 unter einem vorwand
ihrer ehemaligen firma nach china
gelockt wird ich habe einen anruf
bekommen ich solle nach china gekommen
um meine rentenangelegenheiten zu klären
ich wollte das eigentlich in zwei wochen
erledigen am flughafen wurde mir mein
pass weggenommen dann wurde ich von der
polizei verhaftet verhört und
eingesperrt
es folgen fast drei jahre tour schreibt
kohlbacher in ihrem buch der grund eine
ihrer töchter hatte in paris an einer
demo für die rechte der uiguren
teilgenommen für die chinesen ein
terroristischer akt für den die mutter
zahlen soll obama gilt als kriminelle
sie wird nicht nur körperlich
misshandelt erzählt sie sondern auch elf
stunden am tag einer intensiven
gehirnwäsche unterzogen
wir durften unsere muttersprache nicht
sondern nur chinesisch wir mussten texte
die die chinesische führung
verherrlichen auswendig lernen wir
wurden geprüft und wenn wir es nicht
richtig konnten wurden wir bestraft sie
versuchten uns mit allen mitteln um zu
erziehen und die identität zu nehmen
gabby nur ist 28 jahre lang lehrerin in
chinas hauptstadt urumqi als sie 2017
plötzlich von ihrer schule abgezogen
wird sie soll in einem lager
analphabeten chinesisch beibringen dafür
muss sie einen geheimhaltungs vertrag
unterschreiben
am anfang waren vor allem ältere mit
langen bärten im unterricht
wahrscheinlich uigurische geistliche sie
wurden gezwungen auf allen vieren ins
klassenzimmer zu krabbeln die zahl der
lagerinsassen nahm täglich zu es kam
dann auch intellektuelle akademiker und
studenten und studentinnen die im
ausland studiert hatten sie alle trugen
orangefarbene t-shirts mit nummern
später so erzählt kelvin uhr wird sie in
ein lager für frauen zwangsversetzt
10.000 vor allem junge frauen alle kahl
rasiert werden dort unter katastrophalen
hygienischen bedingungen interniert
gefoltert und vergewaltigt als kelby nur
für eine medizinische behandlung zu
ihrer tochter in die niederlande reisen
darf setzt sie sich dort ab der preis
die chinesische regierung hat meinen
mann nicht ausreisen lassen und ihn
gezwungen sich von mir scheiden zu
lassen er musste behaupten dass alles
was ich über die lageberichte eine lüge
sei
kohlbacher und kelvin uhr reisen nun mit
ihren augenzeugenberichten durch elf
deutsche städte so hoffen sie auf mehr
gehör für ihr volk die uiguren und ihren
kampf um menschenrechte